all right andrea
hi welcome back actually
got to be back how's everything with you
i sound so
kind of weather the heat yeah it's very
hot
i hate a bit much for me but i'm
handling it
how's your is your hotel room got air
conditioning
no i don't have air conditioning i don't
even have a fan right now i have to
i just keep my door up
what's your favorite thing about living
on skid row
ah is there anything that you like about
steve
let me ask you for the rent i have for
my rent
and the food is free for my rent and
food is really those my favorite things
about cigarettes
what about the rent my favorite things
about chevron i can afford my rent and
the food is free you can afford your
rent and the food
is free um yeah do you have
do you have anything that you don't like
about skid row
uh i know when you're walking
or you're walking the street walking
down the street right here with some of
my little bastards
and somebody's trying and somebody tries
to sell you dope
and you try ignoring them and they're in
your breath
it's territory exactly you know that
kind of
that's that's one of the that's a
behavior i just psychologically grow
yeah so you have you tried the other
yeah i know you smoked spice
have you tried any other drugs crack or
crystal meth or heroin
uh i have a password cry
you have a past with crack yeah
i thought god sent in jesus christ to
get off of crime
11 years ago i
said it just trusted yeah i forgot
because that was an english scandalous
[ __ ] on that [ __ ]
i have a soundless queen i have a queen
selfish pride and purse
oh i was on [ __ ] i was
but i was evil what does spice help you
do
i have to make me do anything i also
relax
a household eyes
relaxing is good yeah
are you happy andrea do you think you're
happy with your life here
now i'm not happy that's why i need
drugs
that's why you need what i said i'm not
happy that's why i need drugs
the drugs the drugs make you uh makes it
makes it all easier oh that's one of the
things i need drugs for to be happy
is it your childhood that you're trying
to hide the most trying to forget about
the most
and now i'm not trying to forget about
my childhood i'm trying to do what
i'm trying to do with my present not
you placing life i'm trying to deal with
my present life it's not about my past
yes your present life
what would make you happiest today
ah what would make it make you happiest
what would you solve your problems today
ah i had the double drop then and some
bremer grinder came back in my life
that would make me happy say it again as
they'll drop dead some ray mcgregor
walked back into my life i would be
happy
something about drop dead as
satan the devil dropped dead got it and
my friend sabrina grinder came back in
my line oh i see
that would make me happy
having a good friend would really help a
lot right yeah
now how does satan come into your life
you say satan
saint persecutes my best shot
i'm sorry saint persecutes me
satan persecutes you yes what does he
what does he make you do
it let me do anything he persecutes me
causes me to lose sleep and
appetite to eat and stop
do you think you're on a
self-destructive path and satan is
coming no i'm not on the cells that
starts to pass
no
how does satan come into your life what
does he do
it persecutes me for being safe pressure
that's okay i can handle it doubt
persecutes me from being saved christian
that's alright i can deal with being a
christian yes
okay
what are you gonna do later on today i'm
gonna give you forty dollars for this
what are you gonna do with it
uh
uh-huh probably i'm gonna get something
to eat after my tb
as i go getting my tb mess
have any more questions you gonna buy
some spice
probably
should i feel guilty that i'm giving you
money for drugs no you should
why not yeah helping me not harming me
yeah well i'm helping you from doing
something more dangerous than for that
money for drugs right
no you're not i'm fine
no but if i didn't give you money you
would still get your drugs somehow
i'm sure i find another way yes i'm
saying
so it depends on how deeply i want to
look at it the guilt
alright the guilt goes away once you
really analyze it oh
um
do you have happy days still do you wake
up one day and go man today's a good day
not too often you're just kind of
surviving now
yeah you get depressed
not really just not happy either
do you see doctors
for like health issues or mental health
issues or anything like that
i go much last year every day from to
be treated for tb meds that's the only
doubt there
i'm happy tb tuberculosis
yes you have tuberculosis yes and i
that's why i'm on the hospital
it's not contagious but i have to be
we're about done yeah we're about done
tell me last time i asked you if there's
anything anything interesting about your
life and you
probably gave me the most interesting
answer i could ever imagine
is there anything else about andrea that
i don't know
hi
it's pretty hard to tell from last one
i don't know what to say to that yeah
you you kind of hit a grand slam last
time so
nah to ask you to hit another grand slam
would be a lot
all right i won't do that to you but
back back back to that the hermaphrodite
confession that er oh yeah secret that
you revealed oh yeah
how does that play out how does it
affect your life does it affect your
life
not really you just have some additional
equipment
right yes that's more enjoyable for you
is it
if i have a lesser girlfriend that's
enjoyable
you're right and i would listen
girlfriends enjoyable
lesbian girlfriends other than that i
don't use it except for pig
got it so you pee out of your mail
equipment
yeah i put oh america i can't look back
i can't hold
my hands like you
i understand like this uh i had to pee
outside
step like this by the sideline yeah i
see you
i see you peeing outside sometimes
that's why i have a hard time imagining
you as a nurse when i see you pee in the
street
in public
oh boy what's your favorite thing to eat
[Music]
i give you money you could use it for
food what kind of food you're going to
get
wow i love the food at corn cafe
you know carbs cafe over there at 7th
and maple yeah
i like their food what are you gonna get
i have the philly cheesesteak with
dinner and right oh that sounds good
excellent all right andrea thank you for
coming by and talking with me again
thank you enjoy your philly cheesesteak
you got well
thank you
you